Eve gany Prigogine patron doit la
compagnie militaire Wagner est mort ce
mercredi 23 août dans un crash d'avion
alors qu'il regagnait Saint-Pétersbourg
deux mois exactement ce seront écoulés
entre sa rébellion armée et sa mort
brutale l'homme d'affaires de 62 ans
avait quitté Moscou en fin d'après-midi
à bord de son jet privé un embrayer
Legacy brusquement alors qu'il survolait
la région de taire au nord-ouest de la
capitale l'appareil cesse d'émettre tout
signal autour de 18h20 plusieurs vidéos
sont diffusées sur telegram montrant un
appareil tombant du ciel ou des débris
en feu au milieu d'un champ plusieurs
témoins évoquent aussi des bruits
d'explosion avant le crash il y avait 10
personnes à bord dont trois membres
d'équipage selon les premières
informations toutes les personnes à bord
sont décédées sur la liste des victimes
aux côtés des prigognes figure également
son bras droit de Mitry outkine ancien
Spetsnaz et co-fondateur en 2014 du
groupe de mercenaires un accident ou un
acte de vengeance si on ne connaît pas
encore les conditions dans lesquelles se
crash a eu lieu on peut avoir des doutes
raisonnables sur le rôle du Kremlin dans
l'incident a fait valoir ce jeudi le
porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
Véran le président américain Joe bid
quant à lui affirmé ne pas être surpris
le 23 juin dernier soit deux mois jour
pour jour avant le crash et gagner
Prigogine tente l'impensable en plein
conflit avec l'Ukraine ou ses
mercenaires sont impliqués ils décident
de diriger une partie de ses troupes
vers Moscou son objectif d'émettre de
ses fonctions son ennemi jurés le
ministre des Armées Serge soyou depuis
plusieurs mois ce dernier cherchette à
démanteler le groupe paramilitaire pour
l'intégrer dans l'armée régulière mais
alors que les colonnes de Wagner
s'avancent vers la capitale le président
russe prend la parole et averti que ce
coup de poignard dans le dos serait puni
n'est pas mis
le 24 juin au soir nouveau coup de
théâtre alors qu'il n'est qu'à 200 km de
Moscou trigogine et ses troupes font
demi-tour après l'intervention
diplomatique du président biélorus
Alexandre lucaschenko qui propose aux
musiciens comme il se font appeler de
rejoindre son pays véritable maître en
communication et gagner pris goji
c'était illustré quelques semaines
auparavant par la prise de backmouth
dans l'est de l'Ukraine cette bataille
longue et sanglante a remporter la vie
de dizaines de milliers de soldats
russes et ukrainiens mais depuis cette
marche contre Moscou le chef de Wagner
n'avait plus de rôle en Russie estime au
micro de RTL Sylvie Berman ancien
ambassadrice de France en Russie s'il
continuait de jouer un rôle utile en
Afrique sa vie semblait en sursis tout
est possible mais la version la plus
probable reste l'exécution par le FSB et
l'Armée de l'Air ordonnée par Poutine et
son désir de vengeance c'est un
avertissement à ceux qui pourraient être
tentés de se rebeller contre lui selon
le site russe d'investigation à gansuro
et gagner prigogi était rentré ce
mercredi 23 août du Mali où le groupe
Wagner est actif il était d'ailleurs
apparu quelques jours auparavant dans
une vidéo
[Musique]